it'll never stop you were probably the
first canceled comedian as far as
politically incorrect
and by the right
and now it's by the left who does most
of the canceling but yes that was 2001
and that was that was by the right i
mean they and it's funny it's the
methodology has not changed it's
interesting when someone gets canceled
it always reminds me of that period in
my life because at the moment it
happened nothing nobody cared that day
was it devastating to you well it was
difficult for a while but if i could
just finish that thought
that
at the moment it happened
in the studio no one cared
no one made any
you know it was just like we're having
an interesting discussion an adult
discussion
a real discussion the president had said
the way we beat the terrorists is go
back to being exactly who we were don't
let them change you so i'm doing a show
called politically incorrect we went
back to that discussion i was just
agreeing with some what another panelist
had said on that show a conservative by
the way now a crazy conservative um
and
it was
the fact that someone in the days after
could take that and gin up the mob
because again if somebody had social
media wasn't even big no but there was
but you could do chain emails and and
talk radio was big and morning disc
jockeys were big and they get the people
who hated me for a number of other
things mostly probably about religion
and so forth but it really started with
somebody i think it was in houston some
just jockey you hated me and let's get
this guy can you believe he said this
and then you get more people and more
people and and you get just a lot of
people going
uh
okay yeah sure i'm mad yeah i wasn't
thinking about being mad but now that
you mention it i'm very mad
and i've seen this play out over and
over with other people in other scandals
and i'm like oh i know that very well
but also you're on an ad-supported
network
well of course that's just how you do it
but the but the psychology of getting
people upset when they weren't really to
begin with it's so interesting and it's
so gross because it's not real it's so
deceptive
but so you were canceled and well we did
the show for another nine months uh
almost my favorite time of politically
incorrect because it it was kind of a
more serious time in america because it
was right after the attacks
and
um we kind of knew we were gonna go away
so we just had a lot more substantive
guests i mean it wasn't the you know how
we met oh no
you know that's me
you know that's i'm so sorry
jesus i meant to say carrot top uh
but uh yeah that we were canceled and
then i mean it was only six months
before i was back on hbo so i mean
for the people who wanted to
slay me they did a terrible job
because i wound up in a better place
yeah but it's just scary it is scary i
uh
thinking about it too because there
wasn't social media like when you got
canceled you had to really be canceled
like it was a bigger deal right because
now you there it's so inundated with
people on social media and cancel
culture that
it's kind of on to the next and you
don't know what's fake or piecemealed
together when you're watching stuff on
social media so i'd imagine then when
stuff is being shared over email or
wherever it was being shared or talked
about on the radio it seemed like a much
bigger deal than what we see nowadays
yeah it's a lot easier to get something
going now you can do it you know in a
matter of minutes or hours um
it did take a little more
work um
like everything did back then
but do you get more vitriol now like
even though you're not being canceled
are you getting more i have no idea i
never read i never read it i don't care
you don't look at comments or anything
absolutely not
[Music]